These are the best s-log picture profile settings,
it s called portra 800, it s part of my sony
film simulation recipes and today I will show
you exactly how to grade it in under 1 minute.
This is a quick color grading tutorial and
presentation of the best s log picture profile,
also called as portra 800
This is a profile that i ve been working on
since my first sony film simulations recipes,
which is about 2 years now, and after a lot
of shooting testing and comparing different
gammas, color modes and settings, I came to
the conclusion that if you are looking for
great color right out of the camera, this
is the best picture profile for slog on sony
camera.
This profile will give you better color rendition,
less noise artifacts and amazing skin tones!
You can find it on my website it s part of
my sony film simulation plan, which costs
only 5$ per year, and if you ask me it s basically
free because it includes all updated 20 sony
film simulation recipes together with the
color filter settings that will give you a
film look.
This are some shots from my last video, this
is before and after, as you can see it looks
amazing and has really natural color, even
tho being in nature we were surrounded by
a lot of green hues, you can notice how the
profile is rendering lovely skin tones and
the green cast is barely noticeable.
You can find the settings to the updated profile
and all my other film simulation settings
on my website
This is how the footage looks straight out
of camera, it has gorgeous colors and if you
overexpose it right at about +1.5 or 1.7 you
will get the most out of this profile with
least amount of noise.
If you ask me, in many cases it s good to
go as it is, the only thing I like to do is
bring down the shadows just a bit to hide
more of the noise located in the darker areas,
maybe decrease saturation and increase the
contrast just a bit to put focus on the right
things and let your eyes fall where it s supposed
to.
You can do that by activating the splines
in the curves panel, and then in the left
corner, select the black point and bring it
down.
i ll also bring down the saturation to about
35, to give it a faded look
This is how you make a basic grade, simple
and easy, the profile is so good it doesn
t need much post processing to look natural
and with pleasing colors.
now let me show you can get the same look
as in the original video
I used the Creative Film Power Grades to grade
this footage, you can find the link in the
description
In the creative film power grades you can
choose from 54 classic film colors presets
and 35 Film Contrast Gammas, multiple halations
effects and afterwards you can export them
as your own Custom LUTs
so let me show you how to use it,
apply a contrast of your choice, and then
manually adjust it your liking
Next browse through all the classic film colors
and apply one
One of my favourites is the Kinecolor
The name is a homage to the first successful
colour motion picture process, which was called
Kinemacolor, let me know if you want to find
out more about that.
Now let s adjust the halation
There is something I forgot to mention in
my last video.
The creative Film power Grades includes 2
types of Halation effects, the Davinci resolve
plugin which has my custom settings installed
and which is included in the Node tree by
default,
but this effect will work only if you have
a davinci resolve license
but don t sweat it, for those who don t have
a license for davinci resolve, I included
manual red halation effect
It s in the red halation folder, and if you
followed my previous tutorial on how powerful
davinci resolve power grades are, you already
have them imported, if not, go check that
video to learn how to use power grades step
by step from scratch.
You drag n drop the halation effect on the
node and you can see the effect is already
showing
now, how to edit the intensity of the effect?
Richt click, enter compound node. A compound
node is like a nest where you group a node
tree to make it tidier and simplify the structure.
Enter the compound node and you will see we
have a couple nodes
check for the color space transform node,
here you set the gamma input, for me it s
slog2 and the output is Linear
Be sure to check these settings to be the
same, otherwise it s not going to work
then go to the second color space transform,
choose input gamma Linear and output gamma
whatever you have shot it, rec709 log
now let s go to the layer node, which is this
one, and yours might look a little bit different,
I have updated the red halation, but it s
not a problem, to be sure it s the same, let
s reset it and re make it step by step
dezactivate the splines
Now select the white point and drag it down
completely
make a node in the middle of the spline simply
by pressing, and now drag the white point
back let s say 25% of the way
go into the blur pannel and unlink the 3 colors,
now drag the red all the way up and wait a
second to asses if it s too much, you can
also drag greena nd blue to give different
hue values to the halation
and there you have it
this is how I graded the footage and I think
the creative film power grades made it so
much easier
with all the presets, I color graded the footage
in a couple of minutes, job that could have
taken me much longer
If you want to find out more about Color Grading,
I Invite you to my Online Course which will
help you easily understand color grading in
a short period of time. It s a group class
which I ll be holding next month.
In this Course I will Guide you in the process
of Grading your own Footage and Explain different
Techniques that will make the whole process
easier to grasp.
All the LUTs will be provided at the end of
the course for Free
So go check it out,
Save your spot, it s going to be fun, link
in description
So that s it for today, hope this helped Clear
out some questions
Let me know in the comments what you d like
to see next,
Till then, have fun and stay curious
Cya